Oh Andy hey Conan I'm heading down to  San Diego to comic-con now are you ready  sure you gonna take the train no you  know it's only a little over two hours  so I thought I'd Drive you know listen  to some tunes on the way down  driving sounds fun can I tag along of  course are you ready now yeah let's go  to comic-con let's do it  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I don't know where we got lost still  can't see it I'm coming down we passed  and Clemente yeah we're off the five we  passed st. Clemente we're not we  shouldn't hit La Jolla by now you know  well the thing is is the guitar so loud  I can't hear the GPS I'm sorry it's so  much fun I get tired of it I know I know  but it's okay hit me up before we go  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Applause]